Hey, buddy!
Hello, guys!
I'm so excited.
I know, this is, like, a super rare Sunday stream.
I figured since, you know, I took an extra rest day
yesterday, I was like, ah, fuck it.
Let's do it.
Let's do a Sunday stream.
It's very rare.
It's very rare of me to do a Sunday stream.
But, like, I took, like, an extra rest day last week, so I'm
just like, you know what?
Let's spoil the dragoons a little bit today.
You might be noticing lately that like I've been posting
schedules a lot earlier than I used to in the past.
If you're a new fan in the past, sometimes I will post my
schedules on like Tuesday or like Monday or something.
But lately, yes, I've been posting my schedules a lot
earlier.
That is because it is a lot easier to figure out what to
play now.
I don't really have to wait on anything.
So other than like collabs, I guess, collabs is like the
only thing that I have to actually like wait for for
confirmation.
But usually I ask about collab for like really early on
before like the week is over.
So like I would know what the collabs are for next week,
stuff like that.
Because I already do have like some stuff.
some collabs planned for next week um like things like that
like i i try to plan early for collabs so that's why i've
been posting my schedules a lot earlier than usual um i hope
i will be able to keep that up uh wait thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you hey dokey can i get a
birthday wish for my birthday today happy birthday happy
birthday to you happy birthday to you happy But yeah,
anyway, Shadow of Colossus, this is actually a game that
I've been meaning to play for a very, very, very, very,
very, very, very, very, very long time.
I sort of know what this game is about because my very first
time watching this playthrough was years, years, years,
years, years ago on the Game Grumps.
Oh my gosh, if I ever get a collab with the Game Grumps, it
would be a fucking dream come true.
Is that Eagle Raptor?
Anyway, I don't think he likes being called Eagle Raptor
anymore.
I think Aaron wants to be called Aaron.
But like, anyway, anyway, anyway, I've actually, that was
like the first time I've watched.
Bro, you know, he's like, I, okay, you know, he's like,
okay, I feel like saying this would like be, he'll be like,
yeah, I'm not going to collab with this bitch.
bro bro do you know aaron is like 37 now i i oh my god i
feel old now knowing that aaron is like he's almost 40 i was
like what no they're supposed to be like in their 20s
forever i can't believe it time so shut up shut up Shut up,
shut up!
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
He's almost, fuck it, he's almost 40.
I, oh my god, I feel like, I always feel like Game Grumps is
always, like, in their 20s forever.
Like, they'll be, they'll be in their 20s forever, but he's,
it just blew my mind.
It actually, it actually blew my mind that he's 37 now.
Stop talking!
Shut up, shut up!
Shut up!
Anyway, anyway, um, but yes, uh, the very first time I've
ever watched this playthrough was via Game Grumps, and it
seemed like a game that I've always really wanted to play,
and I've always actually played, I'm trying to remember the
developer of Shadow Colossus.
Who are the developers of Shadow the Colossus?
I talked about, I told a story before, but, uh, well, Team
Eco or ICO.
I don't know if it's Eco or ICO.
Um, but, uh, basically, the, the only game I've ever played
from them was the one regarding, like, the shadow people.
God, what was that game called?
I did, I was, like, so young when I played that game,
because I always saw it, saw, like, demos of it.
You could play the demo of it.
And then I was like, oh my God, dad, buy this game for me.
demo looks so fucking cool and then i bought the game and
then oh it's the same it is also eco okay it's also it's
also eco okay anyway and the thing is i was a really stupid
kid and i'm a very stupid adult too so like you know at
least it's like at least i'm consistent uh you know at least
at least i'm consistent in terms of like how this goes but
basically as a kid i was really fucking um never didn't
change at all uh anyway but uh I try to play it I bought the
game and I try to play it I had no idea what the fuck I was
doing because these games there's no actual instructions
it's all about using like like context clues and being
intuitive but like I didn't have that as a kid I still don't
have that as an adult I think I was just born wrong um but
know what the fuck to do because all i could remember was
just running around and slapping people with a wooden sword
and i didn't know what to do i was so fucking frustrated i
spent hours trying to i like when i bought the game i spent
like hours uh like trying to play the game trying to figure
out what to do and i was just running around as this little
kid fucking whacking shadow people with a wooden sword and i
was so fucking frustrated i was like why do i have a wooden
sword.
Where are the real weapons?
Where's the princess?
And then I stopped after that.
I literally played a couple of hours one day and then I
never touched a game again.
I never touched a game again after that.
And that was my only experience playing their games.
And I never played any other games that they made.
Oh no, that's a lie.
I played the Guardian.
It was also, like, when it came out, it was a beautiful
game.
But, like, I think I also played for one day.
I played for one day.
Because I think I got stuck in an area.
Because, like I said, these games, it's all about being able
to figure stuff out yourself.
And then, so, like, I must have been stuck somewhere.
Because I got so fucking frustrated that I stopped playing
after one day.
so I am consistent throughout this and because of this but I
saw you know I saw other game girls playing it and it seemed
really fun so I was like you know what maybe this time it
will be different because this time I have chat to yell at
me if I get lost because I know for this game really depends
on like how many um it really depends on where you know what
to do like what where you have to go type deal because if
you know where to go this game is like two to three hours
because you're just going a destination destination
destination if you don't know where to go like me it can be
a very long game so it really depends on like how this is
gonna go if i'm gonna find and shit like that.
If I'm going to find the big scary monsters that I have to
kill.
Because it's all about trying to find the big scary
monsters.
I have no idea.
Like, obviously people...
I think the internet...
Yeah, forums existed.
But, like, I'm pretty sure this game had a fucking game
guide.
I am so 100% sure.
There has to be a game guide for this.
Because, like, how the fuck were people able to figure out
where they go?
Like, how the fuck were people...
able to figure this out oh yeah and the lizards oh i forgot
about the lizards apparently i have to beat up some lizards
too oh my god for like extra health or something i don't
know i don't remember i i don't remember from the uh all my
all the knowledge i have is just from like just sort of
remembering from never on game grounds yeah anyway oh to
upgrade my stamina yeah okay this is gonna hope you guys
don't hate me too much for ruining this game for you guys.
I hope you guys don't hate me that much.
Also, is my sound guy here today?
Ooh, photo mode.
Hell yeah.
Let's do photo mode.
Cinematic mode, performance mode, midnight mode.
I don't know.
We'll just do that.
That seems fine.
Um, I don't know.
My sound guy is alive right now.
Let me double check.
He is a sound Okay, don't worry, Soundguy.
He's here.
He typed to...
Soundguy, you have a YouTube account.
Use that.
Let me know you're here via YouTube.
Rock, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Getting lost, wanting backseat.
What I'm hearing is Doki needs other wilds in her life.
The game that tracks backseaters.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, just...
Okay, until only one...
Wait, where is the other one?
don't even see the other there's another one i i don't know
i don't even see the other sigil by the way guys i still i
still haven't upgraded my monitor so like my monitor is
still the shitty one so i might get an upgrade soon um and
thank you for that five give the shows thank you thank you
all right i don't know the name sounds gonna be it i'm gonna
boost it up a little bit there you go that should be good
right bird also if i'm looking to the right allies because
like that's where chat is that's really it i'm just looking
at chat
lore time yeah there's no like actual dialogue in this game
me smile and
that's our horse i
can't wait to kill only one boss in this game i bet you i'm
gonna spend like half of this 90 of stream just trying to
find one guy okay you can bring it up more okay all right
let me know if that's better oh it's like the re it's the
ps4 version so i'm pretty like the remake it's like a little
bit better all right is the sound better sound guy the
soundtrack's beautiful though i have to admit the
soundtrack's really really nice it's worse how can it be
worse is the ps4
normal size thank you super chat thank you don't be too hard
on your up dokey I managed to find three bosses how
can it be work there's 16 bosses okay I did not realize
there are 16 bosses in this game I don't know how the fuck I
was able to watch 16 bosses that's me yeah soundtrack is
pretty amazing I
heard that you're planning on releasing a new console soon
really Like, this year and next year, maybe?
You're a nerd.
Shake my head.
Thank you for the super chat.
What did I do?
Moon, thank you for the first super chat to call me a nerd.
What the fuck did I do?
You see, to be a nerd, you have to be smart.
There's no way the graphics are worse than the original PS2.
There's no fucking way.
like fucking nostalgia glasses on if you think if you think
the original had better graphics there's no fucking way the
ps2 graphics it's like going back you're like oh yeah that
was the best fucking game i've ever played back in the ps2
era and you were playing now and you're like it was just
nothing better to do all
right settings audio Look, the PS2 was great.
I would admit, I love the PS2.
But you have to admit that there's a lot of nostalgia factor
going into the PS2.
Okay, nice, show tutorial.
That's what I need.
Uh...
It controls audio.
I think that's good, right?
Yeah.
We should be good now.
No, of course there's no motion blur.
But what would the hard version be?
they'll be harder to find like like what's the hard version
gonna be will they be like harder to find how do you make
this harder oh yeah instead of like in this open area you
gotta go to like all the way to the end of the map and then
you're gonna find this one stone and you have to make sure
you hit that one stone to be able to be To be able to get
there.
And then the boss will show up.
But then, when the boss shows up, that's not when you engage
the fight.
Because after that, you have to find the third stone.
That's, like, on the other side of the map.
And then you hit that third stone.
And then you go back to the second stone.
And then he'll show.
And then he'll show up.
That is the hard mode.
It looks almost like you just get less stamina.
Oh, okay.
Because someone was like, Doki, you just get less stamina.
Well, when I find my princess.
The hard version.
It's more cutscenes because you find out their backstory and
then you take emotional damage on top of it.
Here's my dead princess.
God, the soundtrack is actually beautiful, though.
And it's actually...
She's half dead.
I, like, think, like, who's feeding this woman while I'm,
like, you know, trying to find the bosses?
Sorry, video game logic.
I'm, like, so spoiled, not spoiled, but I'm so corrupted by
video game realism in the, like, current times.
Because everything has to be super duper fucking realistic.
now when it comes to video games.
So now I'm wondering, what the fuck is like, it's like she's
in a coma, right?
So when you're in a coma you have to like make sure they
don't get bed sores, which is basically if the skin has too
much pressure, it starts like breaking apart.
And I'm going to be gone for a long time.
Who's gonna bathe her and feed her and make shit she's like
turn around oh she's actually dead dead
you so you little cock i use the you're called a lawyer
I wonder if that's a real language or he was they were just
like just go wild man
Well, the Sims language is an actual language.
I've shown it before, but the Sims is an actual real
language.
I'm just wondering if they, when they told a voice actor to,
like, read this, if they were, like, just fucking go wild,
man.
I don't know.
It's just like, no, no.
Yeah, it is.
If you, like, there's, like, it's called Simlish.
Simlish or something.
And then there's, like, actual songs.
Wait, you guys don't know about.
Simlish?
Okay, after I kill these shadow people, I need you guys to
listen to Simlish.
It's actually crazy.
Because, like, they've had, like, real songs.
They've had real... I don't... Okay, I might get
demonetized, but, like... They've had real songs translated
into Simlish, and they got, like, the actual rights off of
it.
It's the best language.
Okay.
I'll show you guys after the show you in the super chat
reading.
We're gonna do super chat reading.
We're gonna do super chat reading today.
I'll show you in super chat reading.
It's actually crazy.
All right.
All right, princess.
Apparently you're actually dead dead and you're not in a
coma.
I got one guide because somebody was like, oh no, she's like
not.
She's half dead.
This is why you are a jerk.
Shake my head.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yes, I have the I need your sword.
That's me.
Yes, my girlfriend's dead.
yes my girlfriend's dead please i don't think i don't think
i can find another one
my jacket what the what just not i don't care about clothes
what about my jacket
That's expensive.
Look, Dormen,
people die every day.
What makes her special?
There's so much fish in the sea, Dormen.
Why is she special?
Is it because she's a princess and you want to inherit her
throne?
She is real to me.
Oh, I forgot Dorm is the...
Oh, sorry.
Dorm is the god.
I have destroyed the...
The... the Colossus.
Dear!
Sir!
He's just like me, for real, for real.
jesus christ is so much work bro just bro why is she so
special to you you
wouldn't get it it's called
Okay, but like it's 16 It's 16 fucking colossus Like okay
one or two That's fine 16 for her What if she like breaks up
with him later Doki you don't understand It's actually 17
because of the hidden one
Okay, we have to follow the light with my sword.
What word did it?
Bro, if I'm, like, the chosen one, like, any...
Where any women would be, like, oh my god, I'm in love.
Okay, there's my sword.
Now be on the way.
Okay, how do I call my horse?
X's jump, all right.
Nice, I know how to jump.
Hold up the sword using R1 And look at where the light being
This way Oh, I had to follow the light Okay, that's where
the Next Colossus is Okay She's a great kisser Alright,
hello Argo We gotta go find We gotta go find The Colossus
for my Girlfriend Okay, to make Argo run faster.
How do I move with him?
Okay, he has to be like...
Oh my god!
How do I go backwards?
Holy shit!
Okay, Argo is so hard to control.
Oh!
Argo, why are you so hard to control?
Oh my god.
Alright, where the fuck is the salamander?
Okay.
Oh god.
Oh!
I am not having a good time.
Okay, it's this way.
Okay, Argo, let's go.
Oh, my God, it's actually...
This is too real.
Horse riding is actually so hard.
Oh, my God.
All right.
Let's see.
Oh, this camera.
This camera.
Guys, this is not doing...
I'm not doing so well already.
Argo, let's go, Argo.
Oh, God.
Okay, let's go.
Go!
Oh my god, it's too real!
Jesus Christ, it's way too real.
I'm just gonna look at the sky.
I can't.
Stop.
Marco is like, way too real.
Oh, it's...
Please!
Go forth!
back up your back up the trunk right here good good job
holy i've never struggled so hard riding a horse
ah please why does it tilt up i'm trying oh oh okay it's
this way this is This is the way.
Please stop calling the horse Argo.
What is his name?
He's Argo now.
My favorite horse, Argo.
Alright, this way.
This way has to be it.
There's no other way.
Argo!
See?
Agro!
Oh!
I think Argo is a better name.
What?
Did I do it?
Is this one of them?
Hello?
Is this the first colossus?
Please.
Okay.
It's up, right?
It's up.
Please not, R go.
All right, we're gonna go climb.
How do I climb?
While holding R to, use L to climb.
Okay.
Wait, grab.
on the places but where can i grab i'm grabbing okay oh my
god can i okay wait i can fix the camera
wait there's filters oh my god oh my god i can make this
look less sad wait what there's filters in this game Wait,
this is great.
I can actually make this game look less sad.
Oh my god, there's Sephia.
Oh my god.
Make it...
Okay, wait.
Wait, we should make it like warmer and make it less sad.
Wait, there's like complimentary.
Okay, what's the difference between compliment, warm
compliment?
Oh my god.
makes it like less sad okay well you're gonna do it we'll do
warm like as if the sun is still up and then we'll have
there's death appeal there is what the what does this look
like oh my god wait sorry sorry guys i'm sorry this is like
i'm sorry the effort distracting you guys with this all
right here you go now i should be right climb why can I
climb climb for the love of God climb it's R2 okay oh there
you go okay oh bushes all right it's the bushes I figured it
out how do I get up though do I well do I go like here oh I
have to go this way okay it's okay I still have a lot of
stamina.
Come on.
Climb up.
That's it.
That's right.
Come on.
Get up!
Oh my god.
Why are you so stupid?
Okay, don't worry.
We got this.
Here we go.
Now go.
Go.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Come on.
Why did you jump?
Just get up.
Get up.
Oh my God.
Okay, there you go.
Guys, I'm figuring this out.
Okay.
I'm figuring this out.
We're learning.
We're learning here.
All right.
Nice.
And then climb.
Yes.
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
All right.
Doki is like slowly mode don't worry i'll be the journey oh
dive roll oh i didn't realize there was a hole there all
right is this your second job as a journalist no i figured
it out i figured it out this is now you know why i quit eco
so fast now you know now you know you know why i quit wait
is there like a way to get up
Okay, grab.
Wait, no, not grab this.
Is it this one?
No.
There's, like, something I can grab, right?
Oh, shit.
There has to be something I can grab here.
Alright.
Or maybe I have to grab it from here.
Right?
What do I grab?
Oh, please!
Grab this something!
Oh, God.
God, all right, we're going to figure this out.
You must be able to grab something.
The camera is showing you?
What, this?
What do I have to grab?
What's the camera trying to show me?
Where's my yellow paint?
Oh, I can grab to the left.
Oh, I'm learning.
My brain is actually leveling up.
I can't wait to go to graduate kindergarten You're the
reason why games have yellow I am the consumer I am the
regular dormy player base Okay I am the consumer
Okay Hold R2 to focus on the Colossus.
Okay How do I use my weapon?
How do I use it though?
Oh, I can call my horse here.
Okay, I'm focused.
Hello, it's me.
I'm friend.
Friend!
Oh shit, sorry.
Wrong weapon!
Oh friend!
Okay, friend!
Where's your weak spot, friend?
Where is it?
What is it?
Where's your weak spot?
Oh, wait.
I have to bring down...
Oh, God.
Where's the settings?
I have to bring down the music just a little bit,
apparently.
Okay.
All right.
Let me know that's better sound, guy.
Okay.
Friend!
Where's your weak spot?
where the fuck is it head oh it's head okay don't worry
friend i'm gonna climb climb on top of you and then i'm
gonna give you a nice little surgery don't worry friend
while hold press the rain press to stab again okay can i
stab this friend oh shit oh shit don't worry i'm like a
little bug I'm just going to give you, like, a little help.
God, please.
Just let me do a little poke.
Yeah!
Just a little poke.
Come on.
Yeah!
It's going to be okay!
Friends stab!
Good friends will stab.
Bro, you have...
Have like a pimple trying to pop your pimple.
Okay, here we go.
It's okay.
Don't worry.
Friend's here.
Friend is here.
Sorry, friend needs to aim a little bit better.
Here we go.
Boop.
Do you like that little back scratch?
See, he liked it.
Climb.
Okay.
Oh, God.
I have to climb so far.
Climb.
No!
She got it!
Okay.
Climb here.
Okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
We just need to recharge our stamina.
No!
What the fuck?
Bro.
We're, like, the most annoying...
We have to be, like, the most annoying mosquito ever.
Like, annoying, like, flea or some shit.
Okay, we're good.
Friend, climb.
Climb.
It's okay.
Don't worry, friend.
I'm gonna help you.
Friend, don't worry.
You have a bug issue.
Don't worry, friend.
Oh, friend.
Please.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Oh, God.
Oh, okay.
How the fuck do I?
Stab!
Friend Stab!
There you go.
We're okay.
That's okay, he likes it.
It's like a little poke, a little head pat.
Guys, it's just a little head pat.
Nothing to worry about.
See, he likes it.
We're like best friends now.
We're like best friends.
Oh, I have to fucking hold it.
It's tab longer.
Oh, no!
Okay, okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I just realized what I was doing wrong.
I was just doing little fun.
Oh, no.
No!
Oh, no!
Guys, I really...
I realized I had to, I had to like, recharge my stamina for
a little bit.
Sorry.
Look, it's like my first job.
I'm like shadowing right now.
Stab.
Stab!
I did it!
Alright, I figured it out.
Guys, I'm not annoying anymore.
I'm just, I'm actually...
I'm actually troubled this time.
I'm not annoying this time.
I'm actually, like, a problem.
Because I figured out how to...
I figured out how to actually hurt him.
Alright, here you go.
At first, I was just, like, you know, a little bug bite.
You know, like, just a little tiny bug bite.
And now I'm, like, I'm, like, a real problem.
boom there we go don't worry it's like it's like just some
therapy some brain therapy right here look at that we're
getting rid of all the toxic juices in your brain have you
seen that where like they do this like fucking thing or they
actually try to gush out liquid from your head yeah i'm just
doing some acupuncture
Yeah, the oil drill!
This is the oil drill.
I saw like...
It's okay.
Don't worry.
I purified you.
See it all better now.
Yay!
We did it!
We got the first boss!
That's so easy.
Oh, is that him?
He's a happy customer.
He came back to wish me a well-good job.
No, it's like a happy customer.
It's like, good job, Doki.
I was so stressed out and now I feel relieved.
He's leaving a Google review.
Yeah.
That's like Google review right there.
Yeah, it must be a good thing you're doing because of all
the black spirits.
It's like oil.
That's why it's black.
Look at that.
He was so happy.
He like gave me more space.
That's the tip.
It's my next bow.
Oh, I can move the camera.
Oh, it's the water.
That's like a house upgrade.
You know, like, in Animal Crossing, where your house gets
bigger?
Now I have more space to put my storage cabinet.
Nice.
Argo, are you back?
Guys, I figure out how to play the game all right our next
step is to find the fucking salamander argo you came back
and you figure out how to ride this horse okay i think this
is like the hardest part of the game
this is actually this is actually the hardest part
That should have found an altar similar to this one.
Wait, I'm injured?
What do you mean?
I thought there's no falls.
There's fall damage in this game?
What hurt me?
There's no way.
Am I actually injured?
I can't tell.
There's no bars or anything.
Hello.
Did I save?
Oh, it's a save station.
Hello.
Save.
I think I think I saved?
I can't tell.
Oh, I have the prey?
Oh, shit.
Okay, sorry.
There we go.
Save.
Pray to save.
Here we go.
I figured it out.
Pray to save.
Nice.
all right all right Argo let's go where do we go where is
the sword taking me where is it this time below why is it
pointing that way how do i go below what
okay little me would never play this game that's for sure
They gotta have chat.
Okay, this way.
Wait, what?
It has to be, like, behind, right?
Oh, my God.
Argo, please.
Please.
Alright.
We gotta figure this out.
Argo, please!
I keep pressing X to ride the horse.
But it's triangle.
Alright.
It's, like, somewhere around here.
Oh!
Is it behind the tempo?
It must be.
Yeah.
It's somewhere behind here.
Camera.
Camera work with me.
Please.
Please work with me.
Okay.
It has to be like...
Behind here.
Because why would it take me here?
I have to climb the tempo.
Okay.
Let's see.
Sword.
Where do I go, sword?
Where do I go?
Sword.
Tell me.
Where shall I go?
Where's the sun?
Okay, there's the sun.
Alright.
Sword.
Guide me.
Guide me, sword.
Sword, you must know.
Below?
How the fuck do I go below?
It's a cave somewhere.
GPS!
Oh, down here!
Will I die?
Well, time to find out.
Go!
If you...
I'm not afraid.
I'm not...
What are you afraid of?
It's water!
Yeah.
Hey, I think I'm dead.
Wait, am I...
Guys, I think...
I like how...
Okay, I like that.
It's not...
It's not here.
even a splash there's like
there's like there's like i don't even sink down it just
like i just
oh my god like he doesn't even sink that's the crazy part he
just fucking it was like concrete That is so realistic, not
gonna lie.
It has to be, like, the most realistic water physics ever.
Just like real life.
I don't know.
Usually, you know, it's like Minecraft.
When you drop down, like, you don't die from the water.
I thought it'd be like Minecraft, where you can stop the
fall.
I realized it was not like Minecraft.
I realized.
Today, I realized it was not like Minecraft.
Okay, how do we get down then?
We have to figure out how to get down.
Because the cave is down there.
Like, it's still water.
It can't be that bad.
No bucket tech.
Yeah.
Where's the bucket tech here?
How the fuck did we get down there?
There's a bridge?
Oh, there is a bridge.
How did I get to the... How did I get to the bridge last
time?
It has to be like another bridge here.
This one, right?
Yeah, this is this bridge.
Okay.
Yeah, I know I could climb down, but like...
That's not fun.
It's not as fun as falling.
It's like the biggest dive board, you know?
It's like the biggest fucking diving board.
I mean, if Olympians can do it, why can't I?
You know?
I mean, did you see...
Whoa!
Oh, shit.
Where is that?
I mean, did you not see me climb the fucking Colossus?
Let Argo dive.
Oh,
it's down there.
Okay.
What dive?
I jumped down.
So many questions.
I want to know how many ways can I die.
Jump, Argo, jump.
Alright.
Yeah.
go we need to be a little faster there's no fast travel in
this game all right don't keep please i haven't found a
single salamander yet we're like stamina they must be like
so fucking tiny because i don't know where they are okay
where's my sword oh there's no sun this is bad i'm gonna go
with intuition and it's like somewhere here i swear there
was like side like there was like a boom boom boom here
right
whoa there he is
he seems friendly look another customer the first colossus
must have left a really good I already have a second
customer.
Don't worry, sir.
I'm ready to give you some acupuncture.
Alright, there's no sun, so I don't know where your weak
point is.
Sun!
What the fuck is that?
Okay.
Friend.
Where is this?
Okay, it's the head.
Who would have thought it's the head again?
Don't worry, Argyo.
Everything will be fine.
Wait, I think like...
It's like his toe.
Right?
His toe hurt.
Okay, let go of your toe so I can shoot your toe.
Oh, unlucky.
Okay, maybe I'll use that bow.
Don't worry, I'm going to shoot your toe.
Nine out of ten doctors recommend it.
How do I use this?
Okay, shoot toe.
Alright, lift up your toe.
Lift it up.
Wait, how do I shoot this?
Am I...
How do I...
Am I stupid?
Oh, I just let go.
Okay, let go.
Yeah, come on!
Come on!
Lift up your...
There we go.
Come on, lift it up!
Lift it up!
Stop lifting up this one!
Yeah.
Am I hitting it?
I don't even know.
Alright, lift it up again.
again okay don't worry slow and steady we'll figure this out
oh there you go see we did it nice all right nice okay how
do i climb up all right it's next second step second step oh
here you're here you're here put away put it away there you
go all right it took me a while all right nice we figured it
out oh god camera oh god camera don't worry sir i have a 100
success rate you'll be a new person by the time i'm done
with you don't worry people We're going to get rid of all
that stress, sir.
Welcome to the doki massage parlor.
All right.
Do we do acupuncture and massage parlor?
Whoa!
Sir!
Sir, I know this is your first time, but I come highly
recommended.
Do not worry.
Whee-o-o-step!
Whee-o- Don't worry.
Do not worry.
This is normal.
This is a normal amount of oil to drip out.
Very normal amount.
Your headache is gonna be gone.
I swear.
I swear, sir.
Don't worry.
It's a... I would never lie to you.
Getting that pour out, you know?
Gotta clean those pores.
Wait, it's not glowing anymore.
Where the fuck are you?
You're stressed out in more than one area?
Sir, where else are you stressed?
Paint the target.
What the f- Oh, shit!
Oh!
Oh, I can't just drop down.
Sir, we need to find out where your second pore is.
You gotta let go, man.
You gotta take some breaks.
You're not.
Unless you're a workaholic, then that's fine.
Is it your nips down there?
Is your nips down there?
Hurtie?
Okay, we need to figure it out.
Where else is he Hurtie?
Where else?
Oh, God.
Oh, shit.
Okay, okay.
Where is it?
Is this bug?
Oh, it's his butt!
Oh, say it, don't worry.
Don't be embarrassed.
Sometimes, instead of the head, the stress can go to the
ass.
And it's not like the flattering type, too.
So, like, do not worry.
You are not the only one.
Don't be embarrassed.
You're not the first...
You might be my second client.
So, you are the first client that I have that's stressed out
on the ass.
So, sorry.
actually you are you are my first you are my second client
so in reality you are my first client to be stressed out
down there so but don't be embarrassed i'm pretty sure many
other i will have many other clients that will be stressed
out as well do not worry i shall relieve you there.
Where the fuck is it?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
There you go.
Stop!
It's okay.
Your figure will not change.
Kind.
Kind Colossus.
Do not worry.
Oh, please stop moving!
What?
or I'm gonna get the good parts of your ass.
There we go.
All right.
One more hit.
And then...
Boop!
You're welcome.
Please make sure to leave a Yelp review and a Google review.
Yay!
Another happy customer!
Let's go, Argo.
Why can't I run?
Oh shit, I'm just living.
Now he's so relaxed.
Look at him, he's like lying on the ground.
So relaxed.
He's free now.
Now, 100% success rate.
Alright, bring music back up and bring sound effects down
just a little bit.
Oops, I just saw that.
That was something that was said 20 minutes ago.
Yay!
Another happy customer.
Zero out of five.
Too much booty play.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What is this?
The anger of the sleeping giant shatters the earth why are
they so stressed out
yeah it's just like like those like famous tiktok clips
where like they like they like poke holes into the head and
then like all that oil drops out all the stress oil drops
out it's just like that okay we need to boost that up and
then turn on sound effects all right sound get let me know
if that's okay Oh, this one's fun.
I'm getting better at the controls.
See you guys?
See you guys, I've got I conquered journalist mode.
Okay, but not the horse mode.
The horse mode is still, I'm still having issues with that.
I'm still I'm still having issues with the fucking the
fucking horse.
Horse is so hard to ride, who would have thought?
Alright, prey time.
Pray.
Pray to save.
Yeah, I said there's a salamander near the shrines.
Is there one near here?
Is there one near here, guys?
Okay, where the fuck is my sword telling me to go?
Sword.
Tell me the way.
Up?
Left?
Okay, left.
Not here.
Alright.
Alright, we're gonna figure this out.
Alright, let's go.
The third boss.
We're at a record!
Guys, we're already at number three.
You know, I had very low expectations for myself.
I honestly thought I would get, like, one boss throughout
this entire run.
But now, this way, okay, but now I got two.
That's already really, really good.
It's really good for us.
Alright, now we just gotta figure out...
Why are there no other people here in this world?
Where am I?
Where are the people, though?
Let's be, like, across, I think.
Yeah, we've already exceeded expectations.
We've doubled our expectations.
I thought I'm gonna spend, like, two plus hours trying to
find one guy.
In the end, in the end, we struggled with the controls at
first, but we're getting better.
And we own a successful massage parlor.
successful massage and acupuncture parlor and skincare we're
acupuncture skincare massage all at one nice this way okay
it's this way wait what is it underneath again wait am I in
the wrong area no right it says down there what no okay
we'll go this way and try see i have no idea if i'm in the
wrong place i feel like what is it called like when you the
oil stuff the oil treatment is it also called there's no way
that's also acupuncture right like it's actually like
hardcore acupuncture where like they they it's like they
literally drill drill a hole Is it bloodletting?
Is it actually bloodletting?
Oh my god.
Yeah, that's what I do.
I don't have a license for it because like, I'm just
naturally talented.
And like, if you're naturally talented in these things, you
don't need a license.
It's all word of mouth, you know.
Okay, where do I go?
It's this way.
Okay.
Wait, what?
Where is it?
Am I in the wrong way?
Am I lost now?
Okay, oh, it's this way.
Okay, we gotta figure out how to get across.
Okay, from here.
This is how you get across.
Oh, yeah, we have a map!
What the fuck is that skull?
Oh, that's where we killed the Colossus.
We have a map.
We figured... Oh, wait.
Is this a shrine?
This has to be a shrine.
Time to pray.
Pray to save.
Pray.
Hoop.
Yay!
Is there a lizard?
A salamander?
What do they look like?
What does salamander...
Wait, is that salamander?
No, that's just grass.
What do they look like?
I don't... I don't remember what they look like.
How tiny are they?
Are they big?
What?
They look like a lizard.
Yeah, but like, are they big?
Are they small?
What color?
White tail.
Oh, yes.
On.
Let's.
Yes, the white tail on these white rocks.
So easy to find.
They can climb?
Who taught these lizards how to climb?
Okay.
Let's see.
All right.
I can climb too little do they know.
I need to figure out.
Little do they know.
Oh, I see him!
Hello, buddy.
I see you.
Bro!
Stop!
Okay, I see him.
Oh, no.
What can I grasp?
God damn it.
I need to figure out why I can climb.
Oh, my God.
Please.
I don't even know what this guy's name is.
I know my horse name, but not him.
I see him.
I know what they look like now.
Oh my god.
Those little fucking pew pew pew sounds.
How do I climb up?
Oh, there it is.
I see you.
I see you up there.
Can't escape from me.
I need your stamina.
It's for my business.
I need to grow a healthy business.
Come on, I see you.
Whoop.
Is that it?
Oh!
I thought you were dead!
Please, come back.
You always come.
That's looking right.
Boop.
Wait, what?
How's that not a hit?
Boop.
There you go.
Are you dead?
Are you dead dead?
Okay, double tap.
Just to be sure.
There you go.
Is it stuck in the wall?
I swear...
Are you stuck in the wall?
Are you?
Are you st-
How do I get it?
Oh, thank god, okay.
I thought he was actually stuck in the wall.
It's gonna be so fucking sad.
Oh, my god.
Guys, it's okay.
He was not stuck in the wall.
Okay, nice.
We got the stamina.
I should be okay.
Yay!
I was not okay.
It's okay.
Pray.
Pray to save.
Nice.
We're fine.
I don't know.
I thought I thought I would just...
I thought I would just walk over it and, and, like, and,
like, the lizard is... The lizard tail is just gonna
disappear.
Like, underneath my feet because I picked it up.
Has to be a...
here oops it's nice to know of unlimited arrows it has to be
here there's like a really weird there's like a really weird
tunnel here so where else would the giant be
all right look i got spoiled by modern games okay they they
modern games today they fucking feed you from the bottle
because they're scared they're gonna we're gonna hurt
ourselves Which is very true.
Like, modern games today, they don't want us to hurt
ourselves.
So, like, I'm not used to having to figure this out myself.
Like, you know, because they're scared.
They're scared if, like, you're frustrated at a game.
You won't play anymore.
Because it's too hard.
Because I've done that as a child.
They're scared, and it's understandable.
Alright, nice.
This has to be a lake, right?
Are we there?
Did I fuck up?
Did I go the wrong way?
Where's the sun?
Where the fuck is the sun?
Sun, shine on my sword so I know where to go.
Sun!
Okay, sun.
Sun.
Alright.
Sun says...
Where does the sun say?
Where?
Sun.
Where do I...
Oh.
Here.
Here!
Oh, okay.
This way.
We're good.
It's this way.
Okay.
I ran past a lizard?
Oh, no, that's not good.
Was it in the little tiny cavern?
Was it in here?
A little tiny cavern in here?
Praise the sun.
Lizard?
Lizard, where are you?
I need to eat your tail for stamina.
Okay.
Don't worry, I can hear.
I can hear his little feet.
I have my fucking bow.
What's your little feet?
Where are you?
Where are you, lizard?
Please.
I'm gonna eat your tail.
It apparently helps my stamina.
Oh, is that the lizard?
No, that's just a rock.
Where the fuck is it?
What?
Argo, please!
Stop!
Trying to find the lizard!
He's right there.
No, there, Doki.
He is right there.
Doki, it's there.
Oh, lizard!
Oh, God.
Okay.
Boop.
Wait, where did he go?
Where did his body go?
Where did...
Where did his butt?
Wait.
Oh, that's the tail.
Is that the tail?
Is that his...
body is that it oh thank god why why did they like sink into
the rock it like slipped in
okay does that mean there's a white one only shrine lizards
are you kidding me then what the fuck was the point of
eating the normal lizard Am I just a freak?
I can't believe you guys made me go back.
Argo, come over here.
I mean, I can't run properly.
What's wrong with him?
What's...
Ever since I ate that lizard, I haven't been able to run,
right, chat?
I...
It messed me up.
My legs.
My legs aren't doing so well.
Argo.
Argo, come on.
Where are you?
You're over here.
I know you're faster than me.
Stop pretending.
Nice.
All right.
We gotta go kill the third colossal.
I mean, we gotta go to another appointment.
We got a new client, Argo.
They're mega fucking stressed right now.
I told you having client base via word of mouth was a good
idea.
We don't have to waste money with stupid advertising.
As long as we make one client really, really, really happy,
we'll never have to advertise our services.
Let's go.
like here okay we're getting better this way is there more
ways to go oh which way oh no oh wait it splits oh no okay
i've always been not so lucky so maybe this way
I mean, look, it's like, there's like a creepy shrine that
has to be the right way, right?
There's like shrines and stuff here.
Is the sun up?
The sun is up.
Okay, where is it telling me to go?
Backwards.
All right, I went the wrong way.
I went the wrong way.
Wait, is there a shrine?
Is there a shrine here?
the shrine palace i can't tell it's fine is that is that
safe station i can't tell there's so many all the rocks look
the same are you
all right pray the save all right it's time to pray boop yay
nice oh this is looks like a really fancy one there has to
be a salamander here why you see you i fucking see you okay
i fucking see you nice there you go there you go no there
you go yeah he has to be dead he's definitely dead but just
to be sure nice all right we got another one more stamina
we're getting stronger our clients are gonna love this
where's my horse what happens if I oh fuck I'm sorry I'm so
sorry it was a joke I
just wanted to know if a clip through you it was a joke I
would never argue you know I would never do that to you
alright I'm just training him.
Guys, I'm just training my horse.
He has to learn how to dodge arrows.
Okay, save the prey.
Alright.
Argo, come on.
Come on.
I know you're hungry.
We're all hungry here.
We gotta save the princess.
Guys, it's all about like...
Our horses need a train too, you know?
Like, what if arrows shoot him?
He's now more prepared.
Penguin, thank you for the super chat, thank you.
He's now more prepared for, like, warfare.
Okay.
This way.
All right, Aria, let's go.
This has to be the right way, right?
Oh, my gosh, this is not the sword.
The fuck is my sword?
No.
Look at this way?
God, this is such a big area.
Maybe here?
Maybe to the right?
Don't worry, there's a sun right here.
That's gonna show me the way.
The sun right here.
Okay, no, Argo, please.
This one patch of sun will tell me where to go.
This way?
How the fuck do I?
How do I get there?
Where am I?
Surely I'm going to figure it out.
I'm going to figure this out, guys.
Climb!
There's no way I can climb this.
There has to be.
Okay.
Oh, you must know where to go.
There's no way you climb the mountain.
I don't have enough stamina for that.
there's no fucking way is it here this is water is this
water no this is a desert
how do I get so lost oh god I didn't doing what's the fuck
is this where the boss is why would there be an open patch
of area it's the opposite of water
oh no it yellow and blue look the same okay water might be
like oh there must be water over there
i think i got it i think i'm on the right patch it's like
the biggest beach you're right it's like a beach guys i
think i'm at the beach chat eventually the sand will become
water that's how beaches work
that's how beaches work the sand turns into water
where else do you think like water comes from okay I'm
almost there see it's like somewhere here okay as soon as we
find the water we're good don't worry guys every sand
eventually connects to water that's just basic geology the
stadium is the sun there has to be water somewhere there's
no way oh god oh god don't worry i go okay here there has to
be water somewhere there see there's water I fucking knew
it!
I knew it!
I knew there was water!
None of you believed me!
I knew there was water.
See?
Water is like right here!
Look!
There's water down here!
Look, see?
Water!
I told you.
eventually you reach water now where do I go I ran into a
giant circle I don't know where to go I actually I ran into
a huge circle oh I got back into the Cabrera, I go!
Back into this tunnel, I go.
Oh my god, surely this is the right way.
Maybe this this time.
I can't get lost this time.
I'm going one way.
There's no way I can get lost.
This is literally like one direction.
Oh god, I'm so sorry.
You have a really stupid person.
That's the right.
please please okay here we go we're good we did it
eventually we will find the area we made it we did it arco
we fucking did it can you go in the water oh my god you can
Whim!
My horse can do anything.
Please.
Go deeper into the water.
Oh no, is this like a water level?
Okay, guys, I don't think Argo likes the water.
Bye.
Do I like the water?
Okay, I'm fine with the water, too.
Alright.
I can dive.
Ooh, I don't like that.
I do not like that fact that I can swim like this.
Can I swim faster?
Or I'm gonna be, like, super fucking slow forever.
Alright.
Watch my stamina.
My stamina's okay.
I don't know if I can, like, swim faster.
Oh, I swim faster if I'm diving?
Okay.
That's good to know.
I don't know what happened.
Ever since I ate that one lizard, I'm super fucking janked
up.
Like...
I don't know.
Don't feel so good.
He's super janked up right now.
Where do I go?
Do I just sit here?
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Okay, wait.
I must be able to grab this, right?
Oh.
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Okay, I thought I was gonna die.
And then, because I don't know how to find this place again.
I don't...
I thought...
I was gonna be like, please, do not make me move.
I was gonna be like, please, I really don't want to try to
find this area again.
Okay, apparently if I dive down, if I dive down...
I can like get there faster But it's okay I just need to go
back up Oh god There's no shrine nearby There must be a
shrine nearby But like I'm already too I'm already too far
in I'm already too far in Alright I can do this I just need
to make sure I don't fucking fall off Oh why are you so
jinked up man Here's some yellow paint Thank you for your
very first Super Chat Admiral Thank you, thank you Thank you
for the yellow paint I really appreciate it Okay, we need to
figure out how to Climb this I wonder if I can I'll just be
able to Okay, maybe
Okay, no Wait, why can I grab this Can I grab this?
Alright.
No!
The fucking!
Okay.
Alright, we're good.
We can do this.
Thank you for that.
Give the ship thank you.
Thank you.
Where's the stairs?
Where the fuck is the stairs?
No, I figured it out.
I just I looked at the wrong way
Guys guys, is there a yellow paint mod in this game?
No, what do you mean?
No, no, no.
It was like I it was a wrong button I accidentally pressed
the wrong button chat I'm not that stupid guys.
I'm not I'm not guys.
I swear.
I'm not that stupid.
I I accidentally like pressed the wrong button chat I like
pressed the wrong button And I knew where to do I swear I
swear I swear Okay This is it this time This time I was just
trying to teach you guys what not to do I was trying to
teach you guys what not to do in this game Because I know a
lot of people this is like their first time playing So they
don't know Like the basics So like that's what I'm here for
I'm like, guys, don't do this, remember.
Guys, I told you, don't do that.
Don't do that, guys.
I told you.
It's a great lesson to learn, to not do.
I told you, guys.
It's a great lesson to learn what not to do.
I totally don't want you.
I'm trying to show you guys all the examples of the wrong
things to do, chat.
You're welcome.
Alright, alright, alright.
Alright, alright.
So, like, now that you know all the things you shouldn't do,
here is what the actual answer was.
all right here we go the answer might surprise you
don't worry the answer is gonna surprise all of you is it's
gonna be crazy it's gonna be crazy all right so what you do
is okay all right here we go
and then you you do that yes oh fuck I'm so smart okay and
then there we go see I told you the answer will surprise you
we did it yay yay yay all right my new client Here he comes
Here's my new client Word of mouth
Look at that He woke up from a really bad headache But don't
worry sir I'll give you the dokey bird experience To help
you relieve that stress He just woke up He's a little angie
But do not worry Where is your weak point?
Not your head Your belly button?
Why is your stress in your belly button?
Sir, sir, why are you stressed out in the belly?
Did you have a tummy hurt?
Sir, sir!
Sir, no, no, no, no, sir!
Sir!
Oh shit, okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Where does, like, where is his weak point?
I can't tell.
His tummy hurt.
Where is weak point at?
Sir, I know your tummy hurt.
You gotta let...
You gotta...
You gotta be careful what you eat.
Oh, what the...
How does that hurt me?
It's just rock!
Sir, I need you to...
Sir, I need you to fucking throw your sword down.
Okay.
Sir, the longer you delay this, The more I charge you, I
work $60 an hour.
Sir!
This is a $60 an hour experience.
Throw down the sword.
Maybe that's why it hurts.
Only see...
Alright, nice.
He's throwing it down.
Nice.
Alright, how do I climb the sword?
how the fuck do i climb what though it's at the back side oh
my god oh it was at the back side guys you're getting really
tough look i gotta start my clientele
thank you for the patenta soup i can bring the music up okay
guys i'm just starting out i'm invest zero dollars in
advertising it's just my word of mouth this is only my third
client try to figure out a climb the sword all right here we
go knock it to the ground the armor seems brittle oh is it
bro i don't know thank you thank you for don't worry
apparently his armor is brittle don't worry Alright,
eventually this puny arrow is gonna do something.
Oh, fuck, okay.
How do I climb?
There's something to climb!
I'm just gonna...
Fuck you!
Even God is fast eating.
I'm trying to figure where to climb, but I can't find it.
I'm thinking!
Maybe I can climb you.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Maybe I can climb this.
No?
I know!
God, I know!
I'm thinking!
I'm thinking God Okay God please Please you have to be more
and more direct with me Wait Wait No please Swing your sword
Swing your sword again Let me cook Oh Oh I figured out I
know what to do I know what to do Swing that sword!
I can't believe God is backseeing me.
I can't believe God is back.
God, please.
I know.
I know this is frustrating to watch.
God, but I swear I am trying.
He just let go his...
No!
That was it!
I was too slow!
Please!
Please again!
Oh, he's doing it.
He's doing it again.
What?
Oh, I did it!
That's what the circle was for!
Oh my god!
I fucking did it!
Okay.
I figured it out.
I figured it out, guys.
I broke his armor.
Shit Guys, I think guys, I am not okay
Yes, I was not okay guys because I don't know God I think
God saved me there
Okay, this is it I figured it out This is it Oh, okay.
Oh!
After 20 years!
God, I did it!
I climbed!
Holy shit.
Don't he did it.
No!
Clean fucking holding!
What is wrong with you?
Where am I teleporting to?
Okay.
Bro!
Oh god, I'm up this fucking...
Bro, I swear to god, kid!
Kid, I swear to fucking god!
Bro, this fucking kid, man.
Okay, we need to get to the tummy.
Because his tummy hurt.
Wait, wait.
Okay.
This tummy hurt.
We need to fucking head to the tummy.
It's the tummy, right?
Or can I stab the head?
No, it's his tummy.
Okay.
Okay, kid.
Tummy time.
Oh, God.
Oh, fucking up.
All right.
There we go.
There's his tummy.
Don't worry.
The Doki experience!
We will let out all that stress!
Ha!
There you go.
Don't worry!
Oh my god, no wonder your tummy hurt.
Look at all the stress.
Look at it.
Oh, don't worry, Sam.
You will be a happy clap.
It looks like a dog with like boxing gloves.
You look at it close enough.
Oh no.
Oh no, oh no.
Oh no!
Oh, we're just gonna rest here for a little bit.
I think we're fine.
Oh, I think we're fine.
You look hard enough.
It does look like a dog with boxing gloves on.
Oh god.
Don't worry.
We're just gonna rest a little bit.
And then...
Okay.
And then stop.
No!
Come on!
Just need to do one step!
Bro!
Let me fucking...
There we go.
A little tiny poke.
A little tiny poke that I'm gonna rest here now.
And then, oh no.
Jumping is so scary.
One more.
Boop!
Is that it?
Is it just your tummy?
Is there anywhere else?
Just your little tummy?
Oh no, now it has to be the head.
The head is always like the last spot.
Up I go Up I go
No, I don't get up How do I get up without having to worry?
Do I?
Do I get up from here?
From up the fucking...
That?
Oh no!
From the arm?
Oh maybe.
Okay, two seconds, make it?
Alright, alright.
Please stop swinging sir.
The longer it is the more you have the charge Sir, I do not
feel very good charging you such a high bill, but I will if
I have to Okay, there you go.
Where am I?
I am here.
All right, don't worry.
Just resting a little bit Okay, climb climb Keep climbing
There you go, we're fine.
We're okay.
I climb.
Oh, God.
My stamina, though.
It's fine.
The hell big jump!
Oh!
Don't worry.
This is the Jokey Bird special.
Every client requests for it.
You will be fine.
It's just a stress oil.
Nothing to worry about.
I did not poke.
I have so much experience.
with this you don't have to worry sir I did not I did not
hit any vital vital nerves your brain is okay you're let's
open the seventh chakra right now just a simple scalp
massage nine out of ten doctors recommend to cure your
headache And now he doesn't suffer anymore.
Now he doesn't have any more headaches.
It's just a bad blood coming out.
Guys, it's just a bad blood.
Nice.
Another Google review.
Another happy client.
I hope they keep recommending me to future clients.
Yay!
No more tummy hurt.
Look at that!
Look at all these Google reviews.
Now I can fit my bed over there.
Another happy landing.
Yeah, every single...
Um...
Yes, Valky's.
Think of the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Every single muscle in his body is now relaxed.
Exactly!
somebody understands.
I'm so good at this.
You're too good at this?
No, they'll come back, right?
They'll come back for more.
No, happy landing.
When I'm done with that puncher.
They land on the ground out of happiness.
But fearful it is not.
I mean, to be fair, it's called Colossus, so aren't they
technically all giants 100 satisfaction guarantee exactly
yay bro i don't think i'm gonna out drink this guy this kid
is gonna be forever up oh he's he's so up a cat in like the
way Okay.
We just live like this now.
Ever since we ate that bad...
The bad lizard.
This way.
Where is this way?
This way?
I guess it's this way.
Ever since we ate that bad lizard.
Life has not been the same.
Come on.
Are you so mad at me that shot the arrow?
You know you need more training with the arrow stuff.
It's not my fault.
Arlo.
Alright, here you go.
Yeah, no one ever complains.
Because everyone had a good time.
This is this way.
No, if he...
Okay, no, no, actually horses can hold grudges.
Like, they actually, like, can fuck you up if they hate you.
That's why you never stand behind.
a horse because like they can actually mess you up you can
actually like break your back if the horse does not like you
but good thing for me idol loves me he loves me because i've
always been like so nice to him oh god i do not like this
area it looks so fucking it looks i'm just training him to
be a better horse chat he needs to be prepared What a real
shit.
Where am I?
Is it a turtle?
Is this a turtle giant?
Wait, I remember this!
Jump.
Jump, Arlo.
What?
You scared?
Okay, yeah, that's...
Actually, I just realized you cannot jump that.
Okay, wait.
But I can.
Can I jump that?
I'm not scared.
Speed run.
There you go.
You see, I'm five.
So smart.
See, I don't need a journalist's difficulty.
I just figured it out myself.
Now, where do I go?
No.
Oh, this way.
Alright.
This way.
I'm speedrunning.
Look at that.
Three bosses down.
um no it's ikea he i still can't believe that actually
happened i can't believe ikea actually sold like like what
the how did that happen that is such a fucking oversight
like oh shit you made it how how did you get here but you
guys never heard in ikea like it was a long time ago by Kia
accidentally quote-unquote sold horse meatballs and then and
then people found out and we're like what we've been eating
horse meat this entire time yeah now we're not then it was
yeah and then it we found out and then and then they're like
oh that was an an accident and then so like, you know, we
don't eat horse meatballs anymore.
Wait, is it this guy?
That has to be the giant, right?
That has to be him.
Well, I don't have the sun, so I have to figure out if it's
this guy that, or in the cave I go.
This is a little oopsie.
That has to be a colossus.
Like, look at him.
Oh my god, it's like a Komodo dragon.
Oh my god.
New customer!
Oh my god, did Arlo recommend you?
Okay, where should we spot?
Head?
Oh, it's a head, okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
What do I do?
Do I shoot you in the stomach?
Can I grasp you tightly?
No.
Arlo distract him!
He likes horses!
Don't worry, I'm gonna shoot him in the butt.
Look.
See, he kills, kill one of them by just doing that?
That would be...
Imagine if I just...
This entire stream, I just do this.
This is the entire stream.
Okay, the environment.
Why am I limping?
Why are you limping?
Let's see.
How do I use the environment against you?
How do I...
Do I go here?
There is a tunnel down there.
What is it?
What's the tunnels anyway?
Go into the cave?
Yeah, I was like wondering what the cave was for.
Alright.
I'll be right back.
I gotta get some extra materials, sir.
Don't worry!
Wait, there's another way.
Oh no.
There's two pathways.
Oh, because there's multiple cave entrances!
Wait, what?
Sorry, what?
Now I'm here.
Wait, wait, my head is turning?
I got it.
I figured it out.
I know what to do.
Hello, I am here now.
I'm gonna poke you in the ass.
Come on.
Stop looking at my horse!
Come on!
I'm right here!
I'm right here.
Don't you see me?
I don't think he likes that.
He does not like that.
He did not like that.
Down here!
Arlo!
Stop baiting the horse!
Turn around!
I'm right here!
All right.
We gotta make sure the fucking giant horse knows I'm here.
I think he fell in love with my horse.
I'm right here, asshole.
That's fucking right.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
You see me?
That's fucking right.
I'm right here.
I don't know if that works.
all right that must have worked right he must have seen me
gone in the caves does he know does he know what i'm right
here come down fight me like a real horse i'm literally
right here
All right, no more horsing around.
All right.
You see the colossus that reaches back.
Okay.
Thank you, God.
Thank you for the backseating.
I really appreciate it.
Wait, where did he go?
Bro, what the fuck he just gave up?
He just...
He just gave up on me.
Horace!
I'm not just a mosquito!
I am your therapist!
And I can see you're so fucking tense.
Stop right now!
Look at you!
You're so tense!
You're so lucky your friends recommended me to take care of
you.
Oh my god, where's the other way to the cave?
Where's the other way to the cave?
Looking, he's looking.
He's casually looking at me now.
Turn around.
I'm trying my best guy!
God, I am trying my best.
But he's too smart to be deceived.
Bro, he just doesn't care!
He doesn't fucking care what I do!
Sir, you're being charged for every hour!
Sir, my rate has now increased to $80 an hour, sir!
Turn around!
Bro, but look at the damage though.
Guys, look at...
Look at all that damage I did.
That one speck of damage.
Stop shooting.
Guys, it's called acupuncture.
Come over here.
I charge... I got better experience, so I can charge $80
now.
I got better at my job.
I'm right here.
I'm right here, horse.
Turn around.
Arlo, please.
Please, Arlo.
This is between me and the fucking other horse.
I know you're jealous.
But me and this horse...
We gotta settle something here.
Alright.
Do you see me?
Yeah, right?
You see me, right?
Oh, fuck, I think he knows now.
I think he understands.
Oh, God.
Oh, he definitely understands.
He definitely understands.
He understands now.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Why am I so jink?
Please.
Please don't turn around.
I am trying so hard to deceive him!
But he doesn't care!
He does!
What do I do?
Okay, I got it.
Wait, I deceived him.
What do I do from here?
Do I just...
Do I just clap?
Oh, shit.
Tail!
Grab the tail!
Boy!
He got boy!
It's the head.
Oh, it's the brains!
Okay, I figured it out.
Guys, okay, he knows.
Okay, I'm right here.
I'm right here.
Come over here.
I realized it was the brains.
I thought it was supposed to be the tail.
Alright.
You just don't pull somebody's hair, okay?
It's, like, so rude.
It's so rude to pull people's hairs.
So, like, I was just trying to be, like, polite.
You know?
It's okay to pull the tail, but not the hair.
Alright, this time.
This time, he knows.
He knows, right?
I'm right here.
Okay, now he knows.
Alright.
Oh, my God, please.
Please.
kid we're gonna kill we're gonna kill this boss the tail is
part of the treatment the hair is always a no-go people
don't like it when you touch the hair okay there you go i'm
here don't worry don't worry it's i'm coming back here lower
your head Come on.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Grab it!
No!
That was awkward.
Okay.
I didn't know how fucking short I jumped.
This time!
He's still there!
He dies and notice.
It's okay.
This time.
He's gonna...
This time, this time.
There's no way he saw me this time.
All right, lower, lower.
Yes, yes, yes.
That's good.
Just stay there.
Yes, I did it!
I told you.
You just gotta believe.
You just, please.
You just gotta- Don't worry!
That treatment is here!
Okay.
Don't worry.
I've never done it with a horse before.
But, like, it's the head.
Brains are the same.
The head should be the same.
It has a skull in there.
It has a skull.
And pointy things go in skull.
Here we go.
Alright.
Don't worry.
We're fine.
Stab?
It's fine.
There's not a lot of blood, like human blood, but that is
okay.
It's okay.
It can't be much different.
Please stop moving.
Okay, maybe if I just stay here in it right now.
All right.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Sir!
I'm not done with the treatment!
I should... Whoa, shit.
Okay, we gotta be able to grab this for now.
bit and recharge my stuff.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, grab on.
You have to keep grabbing on.
Oh, God, he's moving so much.
He's moving so much.
It's so hard.
That's okay.
It's fine.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh, God, this is so difficult.
Okay, I'm just gonna recharge it here.
He's chilled.
I'm like a little, like, headfly.
like those like little birds that just stand on the head of
like some fucking lion they're just like whatever it's okay
you don't need to see the stamina everything is okay as long
as long as it's working hold your horses
so we're just recharging a little by little and then step
God, you're so fucking stressed.
Isn't Martha?
Are you in the kids alright?
Did she take the kids?
Sir, I don't think therapy can...
I don't think...
I don't think massage.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Okay.
Oh, hey, there's this.
You might as well stab this dude.
I mean, it's here.
Oh, I might as well.
It's just like a little bonus area, too.
Nice.
He's less stressed.
Oh, wait.
What the fuck?
How did you wake up?
Oh, no.
Look, I think you need more than just massages, man.
I know, like, you have some extra spending money now that
you don't have to have to worry about, like, Martha and the
kids.
But, bro, you gotta, get...
You gotta, like, actually go to therapy, man.
Massages aren't therapy.
Oh, shit.
He's a stress.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I can relax a little bit.
I can relax a little bit here.
All right.
But holy shit, look at all these pent-up blood.
Don't worry.
The best I can do is make you forget just a little bit.
All right.
You're just a few more stabs.
What do you mean?
His child support payments are colossal.
Now he's relaxed forever.
I'm not licensed or anything.
But I don't need to be licensed.
I'm just that talented.
Yay.
So look, now he doesn't have to worry about the kids for
today.
Yay!
I leveled up!
Now I charge $100 an hour.
Another 10 out of 10 review.
Dracula, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
I'm so good at my job.
Oh my god!
So many Google reviews.
If you're good at your job, you don't need a license.
I fixed depression.
10 out of 10 my wife left me
and then and then for some reason there were more ikea
meatballs after that hmm
arlo what are you doing are you looking at my girlfriend for
10 out of 10 10
Pass the colossus shadow across a misty lake.
Oh, is this a fish, colossus?
Is this a...
I fucking was playing for two hours?
Okay, this game fucking makes time pass by so fast.
This does not feel to, like, two hours.
I did not feel like I was playing for two hours.
Holy shit.
Damn.
That means I've only...
Oop!
Okay, gotta pray.
Pray to save.
Pray.
Alright.
Where do we go?
Sword!
Tell me where do I go!
Where the fuck do I go, Sword?
Where is it telling me?
What?
This way?
I have to go to the lake.
Here.
Okay.
Alright, Arlo.
Arlo, come over here.
I need to go to a lake now.
I'm gonna do good progress.
I got, like, poor clients so far.
Will you guys let me drill a hole into your head to let out
your stress?
For, like, $100 an hour?
Sure.
Why not?
It is like a fucking deal.
A good bargain.
Chat.
It is actually like 100% an absolute steal.
Guys, but what about the stress blood?
The stress oil.
Think about the stress oil.
Chat.
You want to be stressed forever?
Okay.
Guys, I am literally a professional.
He's this way.
I am a professional, too, chat.
Your head is in good hands.
That's actually...
Like, look at all my happy clients, guys.
God, where are they?
Please.
Wait, where do I go?
network walked the wrong way you have come like I learned it
okay alright like these my clients were so fucking relaxed
that they like they left they like started surrounding me
after I they were so relaxed that they visited me when I'm
asleep that's how good of a client I am alright good of a
that's how good of a fucking uh massage therapist i am let's
see it has to be like here right well i don't have the sun
anymore to help me so i assume it is i assume it's like in
this area yeah they entered a deep sleep they've never been
as relaxed as i as i've made them oh is that shrine Oh, I
have to dive, right?
I have to dive down here?
I have to swim down here, yeah.
BOOM!
It's not eternal sleep, it's just sleep-sleep.
That's different.
Is it this way?
I can't tell.
The sword was gone.
I hope I'm going the right way.
Where am I?
I hope I hope I'm going the right way.
One fear.
The fuck?
How do I...
I'm trapped.
I'm so trapped.
Where do I go?
Oh!
A clam.
Okay.
Climb time.
Climb.
time.
Um.
Alright.
Let's see if the Colossus is here.
Is it here?
God hasn't told me anything yet.
God?
Am I...
Am I at the right area?
I am!
Thank you, God.
I knew it.
Thank you, God, for telling me where to go.
Oh, it's a bird!
It's a bird colossus.
God, it's tired of me.
Hello, God.
Oh, he's so cool.
I love the design.
The design's really pretty.
Wait, this one's difficult?
No.
What do I do?
Can I die?
No, I'm okay.
All right, I think I have to, like, go somewhere, right?
Don't worry.
I do not swim very fast.
Give me a sec.
I am trying my best.
Yeah, it reminds me of the Crow Pokemon.
And, uh, yeah, it reminds me of the Crow Pokemon.
All right.
Don't worry, Crow.
Don't worry, I haven't massaged your crow before, but I
think it's the same anatomy as a person.
It can't be that different.
A head is a head.
There's a brain.
Did you see me?
I'm friendly!
The horse sent me!
Diesel's still alive!
The horse sent me.
He's still alive.
I'm friendly.
Where you're weak point?
Head?
I assume it's the head.
Okay, let's see.
Ooh, the music is really nice, though.
Alright, let's see.
I'm gonna have to swim to over there.
I don't know if I'm gonna swim to him or something.
It's like there's so many.
There's so many pillars.
Do I swim to him?
All right, I'm gonna say hi.
Don't do anything dumb.
Hello, bird.
I'm friendly.
I'm so friendly.
All your friends like me.
I'm just here to give you a nice massage.
And some acupuncture.
And like letting some extra stress oil out of your head.
Oh, okay.
Don't worry.
I'm in the water.
I can't.
Give me a secro.
I need to go back onto the wall.
Oh my god.
I feel like I'm fucking drowning.
Why?
Like the way he fucking swims.
It looks like I'm actually drowning.
Thank you, God.
I can always count on you to backseat me, God.
Crew!
Whoop!
You see me?
Yeah, that's me!
Are we gonna be okay?
Whoa!
Nice.
Oh, not nice!
Not nice!
God!
What do I do?
Oh, God.
What the fuck?
I can't climb that.
Oh, no.
Come on!
Come on, kid!
Kid!
Come up!
Okay, there we go.
Thank fucking God.
kid please for the love of god just get on his back i need a
recharge kid you're not you're not getting younger your
stamina is lowering okay nice okay nice okay we're good
we're good we're good we're good oh i didn't mean to do that
where the is your weak point Oh god Oh god
Where is it?
Where is it pointing to?
Oh, it's on the wing!
It's the left wing!
I figured it out!
Okay.
Just run.
Just fucking run!
Okay.
we're fine oh please please just grab onto it he has to
glide one time all right nice we're just gonna run we're
just gonna run here you go there you go oh my god you're
putting too much stress on the wing you're putting way too
much stress on the wing
stop oh god oh god oh god oh my god oh okay There you go.
There you go.
Okay, I should not have given it a little poke.
The poke might have been too tiny.
Oh no!
Come on!
Yes!
All right.
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Turn around!
Woo!
What?
No!
He fucking pushed me off.
I'm so sad.
he pushed me up he has to fly back to me right come on maybe
i can like maybe i can like uh if he'll fly back right bird
come back come on birdie come on Just Just here to give you
some therapy You know the drill He's just looking at me Oh
okay You gonna be okay
Look man You're really fucking tense bro Oh Oh Yes I grabbed
it Can I go up I don't know Okay All right, he's coming
over.
All right, nice.
I need to make sure.
Oh, oh.
All right, stop.
Please, we have to be centered.
We have to be...
You need to relax.
When was the last time you stopped flying?
You know, birds don't have...
Wait, there's no stress point here.
No!
Why did I jump?
Why did I...
I don't know why I jumped That was an accident That was a
little oopsie There was no stress point Where was it Okay I
was so confused Oh you need the sword out I'm so my god Why
can't I just like Fucking poke it with my arrow It's the
same thing.
It's both pointy.
It's literally the same thing.
Both pointy.
You see me?
I know you see me.
You can't ignore me forever.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Okay, let me go to the other one.
Let me go.
All right, there you go.
You have to come back, right?
There we go.
All right.
Why can't I have a magic bow, too?
God bless my bow.
God, I need you to bless my other weapon.
This is not fair.
This is not fair!
All right, I need you to come back.
back I need I need you to come back sir sir you're not gonna
like the bill when I send it to you look even if you don't
like this treatment it is for the sake of longevity it's so
you can live longer don't you want to live longer all that
stress is not good for your heart what are you have a heart
attack while flying what do you do okay let's poke him gotta
poke him all right got my sword bird come down bird there's
no fucking there's no bargains for this oh shit xfl where
did he go Bird!
I'm on the wrong platform?
No.
This is the right one.
This is it.
Come down.
I know you're going to do this.
That's right.
There's no coupon code!
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
I need to fucking head over to the...
God.
Dude, this...
Why is this so difficult?
oh no i don't like this okay all right come on no i keep
getting greedy i'm going for the tail fuck this no no no no
no no no no no no no i know you can hold on to hold on to it
you have buff arms there you go yeah i gave up i'm gonna go
for the wing i'm not gonna risk it i'm not risky there you
go yeah nice oh thank God okay oh my god look at all the
stress oil look at all the stress oil you're gonna take me
later flying is gonna be so easy after I'm done trust oh god
oh god oh please no no no no no no no no no
No, let me back up.
Let me back up.
Just let me fucking...
Oh, God.
No!
Please be... Please be water.
Okay, it's water.
It's water.
Yeah, it's a stress oil.
You know, like when you squeeze your face and all the oil
comes out, that's what I'm doing right now.
I'm just squeezing really, really hard.
That's what I'm doing.
all right where is he the fuck is he wait where did he go
he's disappeared i actually don't know where he is what the
fuck is the oh there he is bird bird bird get down here
Please.
You have too many wings.
You have to...
Bird, please!
I know you see me.
Your eyes are red.
I know you acknowledge my existence.
That's right.
Okay.
We go and...
Jump!
There we go.
I hate that, like, grab onto it first and I don't move.
That shit is so frustrating.
Oh my god.
He is, like...
The most frustrating boss!
He's actually so frustrating.
Oh my god.
Okay, nice.
Alright, another hit.
Alright, just doing a little barrel roll.
But we're okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
There's no more stress.
less stress now!
You're less strong!
We're going to the back of the wing.
We're going to the back of the wing now.
I'd rather deal with the wing stress here.
Oh god.
Please go up.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Look at all the stress points.
Don't worry.
Dr. Doki is here.
The doctor is my first.
name it's not the medical time of doctor that's just my
first name okay thank fucking God oh I shouldn't just do the
little pokes I should actually hold my sword up oh no one
more wing no okay we're fine we're just balancing ourselves
We're fighting against a win here.
Dr. Doki.
My first name is Doctor.
My middle name is Professor.
And then, um...
And then, uh, my last name is Doki.
So, so I'm Dr. Professor Doki.
So I'm almost licensed, you know?
It's almost like being licensed.
Because it's like recognized by the government God, please
please show me the other wing.
Show me the other wing right now.
All right, here you go All right Staff oh god, that's almost
the hardest Beijing doctor professor dokey
Oh show you my wing, please respond.
Yay!
License upgrade.
Now I charge $150 an hour.
I'm getting like...
Uh...
Wait, if I dive down, they can't catch me.
The shadows can't catch me if I swim under.
Wait, where is the shadow?
Oh, never mind.
Guess I drown.
he's so relaxed now he went back to the sea he returned to
the ocean that's how relaxed he is
he like devolved so when you're so relaxed you just devolved
yay that's where i'm gonna put my toilet i'm
doing it guys Master massage therapist.
Well, is a giant lurked underneath the temple?
Well, it is not.
What kind of Colossus is that?
I think we're making really good progress.
I'm going to look at my dead girlfriend now.
A little dead girlfriend.
Don't worry.
Apparently you're worth it.
I swear.
If you break up with me after I did all of this.
I swear to God.
Okay.
Time to go find...
Time to go find the other Colossus.
That would be very tragic.
I'd feel so sorry for this kid.
What?
I wore a boyfriend toki.
That got so dark.
Alright, time to pray.
Pray.
Pray to save.
Alright, where do we go?
Arlo, where do we go?
Arlo!
We go...
This way.
Alright.
Alright, Arlo.
You know what?
Let us do...
I know this is a short stream today.
But I think that is a good place to stop it.
I think six...
What, five bosses?
I think five bosses was good progress.
Five bosses was pretty good progress.
I did pretty well!
I'm pretty sure.
Doki's massage uh massage clinic is growing and I'm very
proud of I am very proud of me the kid and Arlo we are doing
so well aren't we Arlo our business is growing it's booming
people are spreading the the glory of Doki's massage therapy
it's to die for
Nuki's massage clinic No, I just got it, Betty Thank you for
this, Super Chat Thank you, thank you Where are Peacock?
Look, they have It's because, like, they're not stressed out
yet Okay, you think they're just going to be stressed out
instantly afterwards?
Chat It takes a while They just need to build up their
They're trying to build up the oil For me to, like, the
blood oil For me to release it Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
The horse is going to be called cherry by the time the last
colossus was treated.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Let me... Wait.
Did I save?
I saved, right?
By praying?
Yeah.
So I don't have to worry.
I don't have to worry.
Whoa.
Wait.
This is not the right way.
Why is it the game?
But what if... Hey, guys.
This is going to be the donation.
Tune in next time for Colossus Doki.
All right, let me...
You know what?
I'm fine with this being my...
I'm fine with this being my chatting screen.
This works.
This... It's been so... It's been fun so far.
It's been fun so far.
I'm glad you guys are helping me not get absolutely fucking
lost.
And helping me figure out the controls.
It's definitely very helpful.
It's so helpful.
But yeah, it's been really fun though.
It's been really fun so far.
Hey, what are you looking at?
What are you looking at, huh?
Yes, I wasn't as lost as I thought I was going to be.
definitely enjoyed it so far i can't wait to uh kill more
colossus kill 16 color like colossus not 17.
i don't care about the hidden one the hidden one does not
exist for me it's hidden for a reason i don't know i'll ever
be able to find the hidden one oh we're finally gonna do
super chat reading we haven't done super chat reading in so
long so i'm happy to be able to finally like catch up on it
unless youtube is down okay no thank god I'm just saying
where the fuck Where the fuck was my super chats Alright
Don't worry I was able to turn it on real fast Let's see Dr.
Cranberry Thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you
Mother I require chicken, grass and maple leaves Please,
mother I require sustenance Thank you for the super chat
Thank you, thank you I'm glad you're enjoying the emotes
Let's see Microw, thank you for the super chat, thank you,
thank you.
Hi, Duggy, congrats on the Razor sponsorship.
Oh, it's not really a sponsorship.
It's more so they sent me some gifts.
So it's not like, it's not a sponsor.
It's like, they just sent me some gifts and like some free
products to try out.
So I'm not like sponsored by them.
If I am, I'll let you guys know because it's legal to like
not put the hashtag.
It's illegal to not put like an hashtag if it was sponsored.
So, so it's more so like they just sent me some gifts to,
to, uh, to try out.
Yeah, free is free.
I love free stuff.
Um, but there is a sponsor this week that I'm really, really
excited about.
Um, it's sort of like a dream sponsor.
So, uh, yeah, I don't know when exactly.
I know it's like around this week.
Um, but when you see it, you'll know.
You'll know when you see it.
But I'm super excited about it, though.
I'm super excited.
Any hints?
I'll just say it's like a dream sponsor.
What else?
Let's see.
Mad, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I shot Shadow of in a similar art style.
I thought Eldering DLC came out and got hyped for a second.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Shadow of the Colossus walked.
So we actually know the...
We actually know Demon's Souls sort of came out before
Shadow of the Colossus.
never mind uh they both they were both hand in hand walking
together uh thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
uh pickle thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
zachary thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
we're getting old doki thank you uh nice chimera thank you
the super chat thank you thank you you say that like dan
isn't closer to 50
he looks so fucking young um for like how old he is like
it's actually crazy I remember when like when I first
started watching Game Grumps and I found out he's like like
what like like a lot older than Aaron and then because like
he looked younger than him so it's actually he has like
really good genetics that's for sure man thank you for the
akasupa thank you thank you hi doggy it's my birthday but i
wanted to wish you a happy birthday as well insisting happy
birthday can you insult me for being a discord mod i don't
have to insult you for being a discord mod because you're
you're you already did the job for me thank you for the
akasupa thank you thank you um uh riss thank you let's do
our chat thank you thank you uh speaking green game grums
today is john charles birthday he's 34 now thank you super
chat thank you thank you it's actually crazy a lot of the
content creators i watched growing up they're all like like
in their mid 30s to 40s i think like i think like the
craziest part is that you see them all the okay i think this
okay i'm not gonna name any creators but i think the
funniest ones are the ones that are like in their 30s to 40s
and like um oh my gosh no i shouldn't say it never mind it's
so it's mean i shouldn't say it it's mean i shouldn't say it
No, I'm talking, okay.
I was gonna say, the ones that are doing...
Oh my god.
The ones that are doing Roblox stuff.
And they're like...
Because like, you know, they started out Roblox content in
their maybe in their 30s.
Or maybe in their 20s.
And they're still doing Roblox content.
And they're like in their 40s.
I don't know.
I don't...
Look, money is money.
I understand.
Money is money.
Okay.
I'm not going to touch minecraft my like the minecraft part
this is why I don't I'm not into like like I'm into like I
like just casually playing minecraft but the minecraft
community is like a whole nother section of do not touch
like the Minecraft community section is just I'm not it's
Like, there are certain places you don't touch and, like,
you don't try to get into.
Like, the Minecraft community is one of them.
Like, I try to avoid what the fuck is going on in that area
of community.
It's more so of, like, the younger the audience, because
that's like, okay, this is how...
This is my... This is my opinion.
But I think, like, the younger your audience base is, harder
it is to control the community and like and the harder it is
to like um how do i say things will get like shit lots of
drama i think the younger the community the more like the
more controversies and drama comes to be so that is why if
you are under 13 and you're my stream you are not supposed
to have a YouTube account unless you have a YouTube kids
account but even then if you have a YouTube kids account you
should not be able to watch this stream and don't say I'm 13
because you can actually get bad I'll say that now like
you're gonna be like I'm 13 or like I'm 12 you can actually
get banned by youtube if you're if you say that so don't
tell us your age do not tell us don't dox your age do not
dox your age but like i just feel like personally this is my
opinion but definitely like if the community of like a
fandom or like a particular just a particular if majority of
their audience of like whatever like you know me like
majority audience are like kids like that's a lot of issues
like there's a lot of problems and ish because you can't
control children children we're i was a stupid child i was a
fucking stupid child that like thought i was the smartest
person in the whole wild world i'd be like i'm smarter than
like you i'll be like you're like 25 but i'm smarter than
you because my opinions matter more and then but like our
brains are still fucking growing and back now i think my
brain stopped growing uh
and um and like i and like i and like i don't want to argue
with a child like i don't i don't want to to see who's right
or wrong like i don't have time for that i have to worry
about like fucking bills and taxes i don't have time to
argue about with you about what your opinion is i just bro
i'm stressed about real life issues
um and that's what i was like i i like i try to stay away in
terms of like communities that are more like children
centric because like i feel like i just feel like from
experience not just like not just from uh current but even
like in the past on the internet history the younger your
audiences or like the main audience like i like if you're
you if you're young and you're watching me i'm fine i'm cool
with you don't worry but i'm talking about like you know if
the main audience base is just kid is mature like 80%
children it's so hard to control that type of community
because especially especially if they're teenagers and we
all know when you're a teenager you love to rebel you love
to rebel um it's playing with fire but yeah that's why i try
i i'm scared i thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you um the horse is so distracting what you don't like my
horse how dare you apologize to arlo i don't know what his
real name is apparently he's a she how was i okay guys i
like how you guys are like arlo is arlo is a she but guys
How would I know the gender of this horse?
They never mention it.
I don't have a game guide to look at.
Okay.
I know this is what I actually miss.
This is...
You can tell...
You can see.
What if they just remove it?
Because they want the game to be PG.
Not every game has genitals!
Except for general justing.
But not every game has genitals!
You don't know that!
Okay.
Anyway.
Was the last guardian?
Alright.
The last guardian.
That game.
Was that bird thing a guy or a girl?
Was the bird thing a guy or a girl?
tell me guys i need to know
yes yeah where the fuck was the genitals there was no giant
pp bird pp oh wait birds don't have pp's sorry i forgot but
it was like a griffin so like it was half bird maybe the
down half was not a bird
I forgot about that.
First, don't have pee-pee.
All of it comes from one hole.
The bottom half didn't have to be a bird.
It could be...
It could be a mammal.
The bottom half could be a mammal.
Yes, the lion half.
Yes, exactly.
The lion half.
Guys, where the fuck was that pee-pee?
No.
So, games doesn't necessarily mean...
It doesn't mean that...
It'll show the genitals.
It doesn't mean...
that anyway what i really miss too is the game guides oh my
gosh i miss i miss it when like uh when you buy a game like
a physical copy and then it includes like an actual like
game guide of like all the cool stuff about the lore and
everything but they don't do that anymore because like you
know you don't have to pay more money and and everyone buys
digitally now everyone does like save money we don't have to
fucking hire a translator to translate the fucking
instruction manual and also we don't have to like hire
somebody to write this up and also saves like the paper tool
the paper money uh rock thank you for the super chat thing
thank you getting lost wanting back seeing what i'm hearing
is dokey needs other wiser knife the game that attracts back
see you're thinking of a super chat thing thank you uh uh
let's see night thank you for the you.
The good old days when the game manual sometimes didn't even
include the controls and was just a short story intro.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Fudge top.
Puzzle games with Doki is just chat plays with funny anime
girl on the bottom right talking about the weirdest things
in the world.
Weird Doki's brain cells piloting the tomato piloting the
skin.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I am pretty sure the more I am as a streamer, the more
stupid I've become.
I'm pretty sure.
There's no way.
I'm pretty sure I've actually lost brain cells from
streaming.
Medi.
I never read those King guys and just winged it, but it was
nice to have.
Think of a super chat.
Think of a thing.
I just like it when they include concept art, too.
That's what I loved about it.
I remember, like, as a kid, like, just looking at the
concept part and everything.
Oh, and then the strategy guides, too.
They don't make strategy guides anymore, because you can
just fucking YouTube.
No commentary playthrough.
Bro, I used to own, like, so many strategy guides.
I owned, like, all the Pokemon.
Majority of the Pokemon strategy guides that came out, and,
like, had the Kingdom Hearts one, too.
Like, yeah, the ones that come with free posters.
We don't do that.
we just like we just fucking watched the no commentary they
still make them who buys them what the fuck how do they make
enough money to still make them i'm so confused how
um i'm surprised they can they still make enough money to to
manufacture the strategy guys uh next thing they give us uh
akasupa thank you thank you i can feel the stress leaving my
body already thank you for the oxy another happy customer
another happy customer thank you the akasupa thank you thank
you um do people even buy like collect i know like games
nowadays they do like collector's editions and stuff like
that but like i'm wondering if people still gosh i swear a
lot of the collector's editions are so mediocre too i feel
like there's not hasn't been like really good collector's
editions lately uh because a lot of them are just incredibly
mediocre when oh my god i'm trying to remember there was
like a really bad one recently it was like they kind of suck
now i feel like they kind of just like capitalize on like
people just wanting to buy collectors editions because they
are they they they are like the fear of missing out and
things like that because they're like oh i don't want to
miss out like it's limited edition and there was a really
shitty one was it the Fallout 76 one.
The Fallout, oh yeah.
The Fallout 76 one was pretty fucking bad.
And like, sometimes the figures are so ugly too.
It's like the quality control is just not even worth it.
They make sure like the...
Um, they make sure like the, the, the pictures for it is
like really, really pretty.
And then, cause they, they grab the sample copy for the
figure.
And then when you get it, it's just, it's just a very
cheaper version of the, the mass-produced version of the
figure and it's like not the best Lolly thank you the super
chat thank you thank you um yeah it's just to trap you in to
buy the collector's edition I also think but like the thing
that sucks that we're all going to digital now for like um I
think the thing that sucks the most regarding like us
transitioning to like digital copies of things it's just the
fact that when they take down the game um itself like
there's no way to play the game anymore like legally and I
think that's the worst part because everything there's no
more physical copies so like I mean they've been doing that
for movies and TV shows now and like um I'm I'm the thing
that people oh did you guys see a lot of people are really
worried that when Gabe you know because he's getting older I
know like someone's no Gabe is gonna live forever he's a god
he's gonna live forever but did you guys hear how like
people like worried that when Gabe like retires or like um
or like is not here anymore that the steam is gonna like
start being like heavily regulated and stuff by whoever
purchased it like whoever whoever owns steam after Gabe
leaves because he's the CEO he's the CEO and like a lot of
people are now like really worried at the moment because if
you guys didn't know Gabe the reason why steam is because
like um every time like the i think like the shareholders or
like stock people are or like who like the board tells them
to do something gab is like no off he's like because they're
like people will be like no you should do this gabe we will
have more profit and gabe is just like no fuck yeah it's a
private company yeah it's like a private company so he's
just like i'm not gonna there's no i'm not gonna worry about
that because we're like no if you do this this you do my
there's gonna be more money involved but gabe doesn't care
he just wants to do a game like he wants to like uphold his
philosophy when it comes to games and um and that's what
people are like really worried about too yeah there's no
board but i'm saying like i'm saying like if they're like
people are like encouraging him to to like people
encouraging him to do that but he always rejects it he
always says no and and that's what people are really worried
right now because they're like obviously if gabe steps down
or like he's not the ceo anymore like people are like oh no
like is it gonna go public is steam gonna become is steam
gonna become public because we don't know we don't know
who's gonna succeed him um it's just it's it's scary it's so
scary because like what like oh man like what's gonna happen
to the gaming market too everyone's like really worried
right now i saw like so many articles talking about it being
like uh just like oh what is gabe what's gonna happen to
steam after gabe steps down um hey thank you for the super
chat Thank you.
Thank you.
I can't even see the ending because I missed a chance.
Imagine that for hundreds of full price games.
Thank you.
I know it's actually really scary for the for the future of
gaming.
If Steam becomes like public, I think it'll be like really
it might.
It's going to be really weird.
It's going to be weird.
I was so sad when they took down the Infinity.
train I actually the infinity train has to be like one of my
most favorite animated shows it's so well done and like
there's no way to watch it legally because they they
actually wiped infinity infinity train off the internet like
for legal means of watching it and it's like um the lore for
it was so interesting i really like the lore um and there's
like there's so many like animated shows too that that like
they took down and everything uh it's not yeah it's a scary
thing to go full digital because you just don't know when
something's just gonna be gone because there's no there was
no physical copies of infinity train yeah they removed it
for tax I don't understand.
I'm not smart enough to understand like why they remove
things for tax purposes.
Because I feel like the government shouldn't like I feel
like the government shouldn't you know endorse stuff like
that.
I don't know.
I just feel like you know
be pushing for, you know, writing things off for tax
purposes.
But I don't know.
Maybe they get bribed.
Who cares?
No, I mean, I care.
But, like, at that point, it feels like you're at this rate.
Thanks.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And we go all digital.
And a really bad solar storm hits.
We're all going to be screwed.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm still really sad.
about uh i'm so really sad about the wally versus acne movie
not being l did you hear about that like okay i always talk
about it but like the recent update was that apparently the
wally versus acne uh the movie um they said that oh what's
his name i really like this actor the what was his the main
actor the one of the main actor in that movie was like okay
i understood it was like i watched a movie and it was will
was it was will arnette was it no not will arnette god it's
one of the wills will forte sorry why are every why is every
comedian will it's like every hollywood actor is named chris
but this time every comedian is named will will pharaoh will
forte will Arnett.
Anyway, Will Forte.
He was the main actor for it.
Why?
Coyote, like, in the movie.
And then, and then he was like, I watched the movie and I
thought they took it down because it was a fucking terrible
movie.
And Will Forte has been in a lot of terrible movies.
So, like, I trust his opinion on what is a terrible movie.
And, like, no offense to him, but he's been in a lot of them
because as a common comedian, you're in a lot of terrible
movies as a comedian, and like at that point, a paycheck is
a paycheck, and it's very hard to write a good comedy.
To write a good comedy movie, you actually have to be like
really smart.
Like I feel like a good comedian is, um, uh, has to be like
incredibly smart in order to write something actually funny
uh anyway oh wait sorry while you kind of anyway as i was
saying and then he was tweeted out and he's like i don't
understand why this movie is getting written up because this
movie is actually really fucking good so i'm like why
fucking delete any of the other other fucking cartoon shows
or movies for tax purposes the loony tunes is like one of
your biggest properties like everybody loves the loony tunes
why would you do this who cares about okay but who honestly
cares about the new velma season 2 everybody watched velma
to hate watch it like honestly
the only reason why velma was doing so fucking well was
because people were just hate watching it And they just
wanted to like live tweet their hate for the show.
And they weren't actually watching it because they like it.
It was like a train wreck that people couldn't take their
eyes off.
So people were like, oh my God, I hate this show so much.
But I'm not going to stop watching it because I want to know
what they're going to do next.
That's going to make me hate it even more.
anyway but yes i'm still i'm still so upset that i just want
to watch wally wally coyote versus acne because it just
seems like such a good fucking it just seems like such a
good movie i really love looney tunes in general i i
honestly loved that um oh which one except for space jam 2
that was just i can't believe space jam 2 didn't get
cancelled for tax purposes like that was my that was just
nostalgia beating but I I know like it might be a hot take
but I really I actually really enjoyed um fuck what was that
movie called I watched it like several times because I
actually really enjoyed it back in action I actually really
liked Looney Tunes back in action I know when it came out it
had like really shitty reviews but it's I personally thought
it was a good movie I thought it was fun I thought it was
yeah but when it came out when that movie came out it was a
box off like was it um it was not good it like reviews were
fucking terrible and um it did not make back its money it
did not make back its money at all um but I enjoyed it as a
as a And I watched, re-watch it several times on DVD.
And it was a fun movie.
Yeah, it flopped.
It actually flopped.
But I think it was pretty good.
I thought it was pretty good.
But I actually really enjoyed Looney Tunes in general.
So I'm just really sad that we don't have new Looney Tunes
stuff.
Anyway, I've been yapping a lot.
Okay.
I'm going to call it here, guys.
I'm sorry I didn't read all the super chats.
eepe now so i'm gonna call it here everybody um i hope you
guys enjoyed uh shadow of the classes part one as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around
to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to
bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time
everybody bye guys bye